extreme heat
extreme pressure so how many people go
on
each helicopter so a minimum it would be
three of us
ambulance services across england and
wales are already on high alert
but as things get hotter things will get
harder for emergency responders both in
the nhs and places like air ambulance
charities we get people taking advantage
of nice weather and getting into the
beer gardens and then the the problems
that alcohol has in terms of risk taking
at the moment the nhs and all emergency
services are under a lot of strain just
trying to cope with the end of the
pandemic if anybody can do anything that
can help any of those services now is
the time
that also means keeping the elderly and
frail safe by keeping them cool
this care home in leeds gets daily
weather alerts it's constantly
monitoring residents and trying
everything to keep temperatures down
what are the main issues that
you're worried about dehydration is is
one of the main ones obviously the
nurses and the staff are taking
residence temperatures regularly and
we're all aware of the signs of
dehydration and we'd obviously observe
people for headaches vomiting
the met officer's extreme heat warning
has been extended into tuesday next week
expect travel delays with it rail
providers are already looking at putting
speed restrictions in place in case rail
lines start to buckle in extreme heat
they've warned that it could mean delays
for passengers and for freight services
too
there are warnings too about water use
especially in areas like east anglia the
driest part of the uk
as the temperatures get hotter we will
see an increased demand for water this
weekend and we're forecasting to be
putting record amounts of water into
supply so well over a billion litres a
day dry weather means drier ground that
can lead to burst pipes on the isle of
sheppy there were long queues for crates
of water after mains pipes broke and
took two days to fix
the stress on services is intense and
well with the temperature continue to
rise
cattle river topsy sky news